marine lepen has had her eyes set on the
French presidency for some time but this
is her best shot to date the right-wing
firebrand reached the anti-semitic
rhetoric that her father used to build
up the National Front party and in doing
so increased its popularity but is that
enough even this year the Front's most
successful showing yet marine lepen only
gathered 21 and a half percent of the
vote in the first round of the
presidential election she's trailing
centrist Emmanuel macron by almost 20
points the pens presidential campaign
centers around clamping down on
immigration and dismantling the European
project with you guessed it a French
exit or exit but even as the pen has
tried to distance herself from her
father's racism her political identity
is still shaped by his controversial
past this is how marine lepen climbed to
the top of Frances far-right marine
lepen was born in August 1968 in noises
send a suburb of Paris her father
jean-marie Le Pen was the provocative
leader of the far-right National Front
her mother left with a lover when marine
was 16 and for the next 15 years marine
lepen and her mother Giotto Ben did not
speak one this is lens through K
Bloomberg reporter on French politics
the shock of marine lepen smothered
departure made her much closer to her
father she lived with him and they also
started doing political campaigns
together when she was not even 20 in the
early 90s marine lepen graduated from
university with a degree in criminal law
she then went on to practice as a public
defender for six years mostly defending
people in extreme right movements in 98
she quit her job to join the party three
months later she won her first election
for Regional Council as what Penrose
within party ranks she set out to
improve the National Front image what
marina banded was to bring the National
Front on new kinds of topics but it's
cosmetic because behind it the party is
still the same still has the same kind
of members
who are the old guard of the National
Front by 2011 with her father's blessing
the pen ran for the leadership of the
National Front and won with more than
two-thirds of the vote nostalgia fond of
donated all the mechanical jaws the
manila community main lobby security so
no problem in 2012 she ran for the
French presidency coming third in the
first round after Nicolas Sarkozy and
eventual winner
Francois Hollande support for her was
growing but she still had a problem her
father
despite her warnings jean-marie lepen
continued to say things like this
Bashar my uncle died his father again
leave Amelie other marks at that point
did that by me Jamal Silesia oh my god
eventually in 2015 the pen was forced to
expel her own father from the National
Front even so her biggest challenge
remains convincing voters to leave the
EU several surveys suggest a large
majority in France to remain still she's
had some success appearing to women
picking up an additional two million
female supporters from her 2012 bid for
presidency basically what she tried to
do is to say I am a divorced mother of
three children I know what hardship is
so vote for me the penny is running
under just her first name but she still
hasn't escaped the shadow of her father
in early April she caused an uproar when
she denied the role of the French state
in the wartime round up of Jews it was a
very slippery remark and it was it was a
good a tackle mistake and it actually
revealed that even though Marilla banned
herself may not be anti-semitic she in
her culture in her thinking is still
very much the daughter of her father
Jean Marie de Ben
you
you